[Music]
the girls quietly climbed in the van Amy
slammed the trunk closed and started the
three-day drive from Washington DC back
to the Mountain West she had done it she
had finally left him after five years of
living in constant fear that he might in
some way hurt her or her three girls she
had finally left him she thought about
the challenges that lay ahead
there had been emotional and
psychological trauma for her and her
daughter's Kira Jessie and Gabi but it
was worth it to be able to raise her
three girls away from the addictions and
abuse she had been to college but had
been four and a half years since she'd
last had a job and she never actually
used her degree
Amy qualified for food stamps and
Medicaid these government programs were
a lifeline but they were also a crutch
to continue to qualify she had to stay
in a low-paying job there was nothing to
help her transition off of the
government assistance to a better life
amy was stuck Amy's not alone in her
struggles as a single mother in this
country there are over 11 million single
parents in the United States since over
80% of these are single mothers my talks
can a focus on their struggles of course
everything that I share today applies to
all single parents mothers and fathers
so you're probably thinking Dave you're
not a single parent why are you talking
about this because Amy is my fiancee we
first met when we were 18 years old we
then went our separate ways for 12 years
during that time she got into a bad
marriage and finally left four years ago
mutual friends brought us back together
two years ago
finally this last Christmas I asked Amy
to marry me because this relationship
because this relationship was more than
just her and me
I wanted Kyra Gabi and Jessie to be
there for the proposal then one at a
time I got down on one knee put a little
ring on each of their fingers and asked
them if I could be their dad they said
yes I am the luckiest man in the world
have these amazing girls in my life
caring about Amy struggles as a single
mother has been so frustrating because
there's so much that can be done for
this talk I'm gonna share all that I've
learned about why single mothers
struggle to escape poverty and how
college and childcare assistance can
help there are four key numbers you
should remember from this talk the first
is one in four one in four children in
the United States is raised by a single
mother this is in large part due to the
growing trend of children being born out
of wedlock divorce and abandonment due
to substance abuse more than a third of
single mother households live in poverty
for the second key number one point nine
billion dollars the government provides
1.9 billion dollars in food stamps every
year to single mothers that's a market
size that make any venture capitalist to
rule these government programs do so
much to help these single mothers get
back on their feet
unfortunately even though they're
intended to be temporary there are no
incentives to help people get off of
them
so I've learned college is critical to
help these single mothers escape poverty
the Institute for Women's policy
research has done a ton of research on
single mothers they have shown single
mothers with a college degree get
significantly better jobs make more
money and have better health and all
these benefits trickle down to their
children as well now for the third key
number $30,000 $30,000 is the average
net gain the government could get if
they were to help a single mother earn a
bachelor's degree if the government were
to provide child care assistance
financial aid and a caseworker to these
single mothers ultimately they would
come out ahead and the additional tax
benefits and tax revenue from the higher
paying job for that single mother
$30,000 a head and that's not even
considering all the benefits that come
to the children of these single mothers
the last piece of this puzzle is child
care for a mother to be able to go back
to school she needs help raising her
kids but childcare is expensive on
average a single mother will spend a
quarter to a third of her income on
childcare the government used to provide
child care assistance to single mothers
while they're in college
but during the welfare reforms of the
mid-90s the government stopped providing
child care assistance to students
enrollment of single mothers in college
plummeted for those single mothers who
have access to child care assistance
their likelihood of graduating on time
triples now for the final key number
forty nine percent only forty nine
percent of college campuses have child
care centers on campus there's a
government program that helps support
these childcare centers but it's
obviously not nearly large enough now
that I've shared these startling
statistics with you we need to act on
this let's think about the single
mothers in her life and make sure that
they are welcomed on every college
campus every college campus should have
a childcare center on campus do you know
if the GSB has childcare if not ask the
administration so that they know you
care I've talked with the GSB Stanford
has child care for both students and
faculty for colleges that are so
concerned about diversity and inclusion
by not making it possible for single
mothers to attend college they're
missing out on this key group of
individuals as a side note we as future
business leaders need to make sure it's
feasible for single mothers to join us
in the workplace second support the
single mothers in your life these
amazing women have done so much to raise
children and taking on the parenting
roles of two people talk with them about
their struggles and ask how you can help
finally there needs to be a government
policy change the government should
provide childcare assistance and other
support to every single mother that's in
college this financially and socially
makes sense to include in conclusion
remember there are four key numbers one
and four one point nine billion dollars
thirty thousand dollars and forty nine
percent that forty nine percent should
be one hundred percent so what's the
rest of Amy's story amy is getting her
master's in public administration and is
working for a government city management
office she didn't have access to
childcare through her college but
luckily her parents helped her take care
of her girls Amy wants to help
underserved single mothers gain access
to college and a childcare
she and I are working on a non-profit to
push for these initiatives as well as
push for government policy change
in her words I don't see this as a hand
out but as a hand up so that single
mothers are on an equal playing field
single mothers like Amy are raising many
of the future generation and they
deserve a fair chance thank you
[Applause]
[Music]